ici ce sont les endroits où ce convoyage
hectic de l'otan
le longer c'est dans cette petite usine
construite uniquement pour faire des
tests que commenceront dans quelques
semaines les simulations pour préparer
l'arrivée de la plus grosse unité
d'ozonation d'eaux usées de la planète
dans ses futurs bâtiments chaque jour il
faudra désinfecter l'équivalent de plus
d'un stade olympique rempli d'eau usée
et trois fois plus les jours de fortes
pluies
parce que l'île de montréal à elle seule
produit 45 % des eaux usées de la
province mais sans ozonation les virus
bactéries ou traces de médicaments
présents dans l'eau sont encore rejetées
dans le fleuve alors nation le procédé
de désinfection par ozone
les annonces se sont succédé à partir de
2008 sans suite aux jeunes et une telle
quantité d'eau représentait un défi
d'ingénierie qu'on n'avait pas prévu
c'était sûrement pas hydraulique qui
pouvait mener une sous performance ou
même des problèmes de sécurité au niveau
des employés ici à l'usaid donc là avec
la solution qu'on a fait on va très
bientôt prêt à aller en appel d'offres
donc le projet se poursuit sauf qu
initialement évaluée à 210 millions de
dollars les coûts du projet ont explosé
on est rendu à peu près à un demi
milliard 500 millions de dollars c'est
la somme qui apparaîtra lundi dans le
nouveau plan triennal d'immobilisations
de la ville plus cher à cause de
l'inflation et surtout parce qu'il
faudra reconfigurer les canaux d'eau
actuels et acheter plus d'équipements
que prévu une partie de la somme a déjà
été dépensé pour la construction de
cette station électrique sur place puis
pour la fabrication de ces aux honneurs
qu'ils sont prêts et qu'ils attendent
aux états unis de l'argent bien investi
10 la ville le fait de désinfecter les
au musée on va retourner aux fleurs à la
main
nous assurer de prendre soin de la faune
et de la flore faut se rappeler qu'au
début des années 80 il y avait tout
l'autre montréal toutes les eaux usées
étaient envoyés au fleuve et offre vers
les prairies sans aucun traitement
on part de très loin et on va encore
plus loin cette usine de the nation qui
avait d'abord été promise pour 2013 est
encore loin de voir le jour
selon les prévisions les plus optimistes
ce n'est pas avant 2023 qu'elle entrera
en opération
ici jean sébastien cloutier radio canada
montréal